Salut #sulawesi Nikita emprunter
vous êtes les élections pour la ville de Madiun et
Et si on isolait notre environnement
Notre hôpital complet du menu de l'auberge Hajj
mettez-le donc signalez tout de
lit commencé alors quoi exactement
départ médical du chemin
[Musique]
Allez, on peut être plein d'horreur
en entier c'est le nom du personnel médical
ça doit être le seul et unique ouais
Nous empruntons à plusieurs hôpitaux
ça commence à être plein Attendez quelqu'un
formation médicale prestigieuse peut-être plus tard
peut être une solution aussi
Dino Island est aussi pleine que possible
les patients qui ont besoin d'un traitement de peinture corporelle
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas d'habitants
surtout dans les villes développées du monde
isolé dans une technique médicale étonnante
assez jusqu'ici résidents ou
ainsi que des patients isolés